This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantantham. Unpredictable things happen to us all the time. Your car breaks down. The babysitter cancels. You get sick. Those little moments shift the direction of your day or your week. And then there are the bigger things in life. The earthquake kind of change that shakes everything around you,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。意料之外的事情随时都在发生。你的车抛锚了。保姆临时取消了。你生病了。那些微小的瞬间改变了你一天或一周的方向。生活中还有更大的事情。那种撼动你身边一切的地震般的改变，
that breaks down your sense of who you are and what your life is. And in the process of getting back on your feet, you might realize that something's different. Maybe you come out of it with a new perspective, a sense of direction you never imagine. Today on the show, we have two stories of that kind of change and the transformation it brings. Oh, and we have some pretty beautiful music that comes with those stories. Derek Amato is sitting at the piano in NPR Studio 1. As you're listening to him play, you might think he's had years of musical training.
它会粉碎你对自我认知以及生活的理解。而在重新站起来的过程中，你可能会意识到有些事情变得不同了。也许你会从中获得全新的视角，一种你从未想象过的方向感。今天的节目中，我们有两个关于这种改变以及它所带来的蜕变的故事。哦，这些故事还伴随着一些非常美妙的音乐。德里克·阿马托正坐在NPR第一演播室的钢琴前。听他弹奏时，你可能会觉得他受过多年的音乐训练。
But Derek is unusual. He's said to have something called a quiet Savan syndrome that left him with the incredible ability to play the piano. We'll talk about what that means, but let's back up a minute. I grew up a typical kid. I was an extremely aggressive athlete.
但德里克与众不同。据说他患有某种被称为“获得性学者综合征”的病症，这赋予了他弹钢琴的不可思议的能力。我们来谈谈这意味着什么，不过让我们先把时间倒回一点。我成长为一个典型的孩子。我是一个极其好胜的运动员。
So that was kind of my thing. I was a baseball football basketball player. You were a jock. I was a jock, yeah. I had musical interest from very early on. My grandmother was a organ player for the church. So I mean, I was around it. I remember Sunday mornings going, sitting next to her on the bench, and even though I didn't understand what she was doing or how to play the instrument, I loved to sit with her and sing. It was just
所以这就是我的强项。我是一名棒球、足球、篮球运动员。你是个体育健将。我确实是个体育健将。我从小就对音乐感兴趣。我祖母是教堂的风琴手。所以我的意思是，我一直接触这些。我记得星期天早晨，我坐在她身边的长凳上，虽然我不明白她在做什么，也不知道怎么弹奏乐器，但我喜欢和她坐在一起唱歌。这对我来说只是
my comfort zone as a child when I go to church. I get to sit and watch her play the organ and sing. At his mother's insistence, Derek dabbled in music. He joined the school band, played drums, tinkered around with a guitar, formed a rock band with friends, but he did not take formal lessons or get any musical training. OK, so that's the setup.
我小时候去教堂时的舒适区。我可以坐着看她弹风琴和唱歌。在母亲的坚持下，德里克涉足了音乐领域。他加入了学校乐队，打过鼓，摆弄过吉他，和朋友们组建了一支摇滚乐队，但他没有接受过正规课程或任何音乐训练。好的，背景就是这样。
What happens to Derek in 2006 is both terrifying and fascinating. What happens to Derek in 2006 is both terrifying and fascinating. He was in South Dakota visiting friends and family. I got together with some friends and we were going to have a little barbecue party at the pool and indoor pool. And we were horsing around and this young man walked in. He must have been about 14, 12, 14. And he had this little miniature football with him. So of course, we started throwing the football at each other, and I thought I could just run on the side of the pool and then dive over the water and catch the football in the
德里克在2006年遭遇的经历既可怕又迷人。德里克在2006年遭遇的经历既可怕又迷人。他在南达科他州探访亲友。我和一些朋友聚在一起，我们打算在游泳池——一个室内游泳池——开个小型烧烤派对。我们当时在打闹，然后这个年轻小伙子走了进来。他大概14岁、12岁、14岁左右。他带着一个迷你橄榄球。所以当然，我们开始互相扔橄榄球，我想我可以沿着泳池边跑，然后跃过水面，在空中接住橄榄球。
air. And the idea was you would catch it and then fall into the pool. Yeah, just catch it in the air and then fall into the water. So I went running on the side of the pool. And I remember, I remember running alongside the pool. I remember even diving in to catch the ball. And I knew I was diving towards a shallow end. I was very aware and I miscalculated the depth obviously
当时的想法是，你接住球，然后落入泳池中。对，就是在空中接住球，然后掉进水里。于是我沿着泳池边跑了起来。我记得，我记得自己正沿着泳池奔跑。我甚至还记得自己为了接球而跳了进去。我知道自己是朝着浅水区跳的。我很清楚这一点，但我显然错判了深度，
and I hit the upper left side of my face. And that's all I remember. It was like an explosion. And you know, most of us had a head trauma when we were a kid or hit our head. And it's that sickening feeling you get when it's like, oh no, I know something. I just did something extremely wrong.
我的脸部左上方撞上了。这就是我记得的全部。感觉就像一场爆炸。你知道的，我们大多数人在小时候都遭受过头部创伤或撞击过头部。那种感觉很不舒服，就像是“噢不，我知道出事了”。我刚刚做了一件极其错误的事。
And this isn't right. And I knew I had hurt myself. Diagnosis was a massive concussion. And what was the treatment? Relax, stay quiet, lay in bed for a few days. I spent the night at the hospital the next morning they sent me home. I went home and I slept. I slept for five days basically. And then you get up and do what? We sit at the table and I said, well, I feel pretty darn good. I know I had an accident and I'm not sure what happened. And I said, well, I'm in a pack
而且这不对劲。我知道自己受伤了。诊断结果是严重脑震荡。那治疗方法是什么？放松，保持安静，卧床几天。我在医院过夜，第二天早上他们把我送回家了。我回家睡觉了。我基本上睡了五天。然后你起来做什么？我们坐在桌旁，我说：“嗯，我感觉好多了。我知道我出了事故，但我不太确定发生了什么。”然后我说：“嗯，我收拾一下行李，
and I think I can go back to Denver in a couple days. So I called Rick and I said, why don't you come over and get me, we'll say goodbyes and I'll be on my way in a couple of days. And so we went over to the apartment and we were just hanging out. And he had this tiny keyboard, just this little piece of junk in the corner and it was just on the stand, dusty and not sure if it had ever been played. And I kept staring at it as we were talking and we were just sitting talking like just like this.
我想我过几天就可以回丹佛了。”所以我打电话给里克，我说：“你为什么不过来接我，我们道个别，过几天我就要上路了。”于是我们去了那个公寓，就在那儿闲逛。角落里有一个小键盘，就是那种破烂的小玩意儿，放在支架上，落满了灰尘，也不知道以前有没有人弹过。我们聊天时我一直盯着它，我们就这样坐着聊天。
And I kept looking at it and looking at it, curious. It was like not sure why I was drawn to it and I finally just walked over to it and I thought I'll just hit a few of these keys. I turn it on and see what happened. I had no clue and I sat down and my fingers just went crazy. My fingers were like somebody just... I don't know, Rick said the ghost of Beethoven jumped into my body. I don't know how else to explain it. I went crazy and just played and played. And it wasn't like I was just picking away. What did you play?
我一直看着它，看着它，充满了好奇。就好像不知道为什么自己会被它吸引，最后我终于朝它走了过去，心想我只要按几个键就行了。我把它打开，看看会发生什么。我毫无头绪，坐下来后，我的手指就疯狂地动了起来。我的手指就像有人……我不知道，里克说贝多芬的灵魂附体了。我不知道该怎么解释。我疯了似地弹奏，不停地弹奏。而且不只是在瞎弹。你弹了什么？
I played... I think it was more of a classical structure to it. And I sat there and did this for, I don't know, five, six hours without stopping. And we just, I remember looking at him and there was tears rolling out his face. I mean, he's a Christian coward, he's a pretty emotional guy. He's a sweet, sweet man. And he just, you know, he didn't know what to think as, because I mean, I'm known him since we were kids.
我弹了……我觉得它更具有古典音乐的结构。我坐在那里弹了这个，我不知道，五、六个小时没有停下来。我记得看着他，眼泪从他脸上流下来。我的意思是，他是一个充满基督信仰的人，一个相当感性的人。他是个非常非常温柔的人。他只是，你知道，他不知道该作何感想，因为我的意思是，我们从小就认识了。
And he'd never seen me play a piano, so he's like, what's going on? I'm not sure what's going on. I didn't want to stop playing because I was like, well, what if I stop and then and then this doesn't happen tomorrow morning I mean this is kind of cool. I don't I mean, it doesn't happen every day You just sit out and start playing a piano. So I think this is kind of different. Let's let's just stay here for a while It must have been two o'clock in the morning and I was exhausted. My brain was flying still is racing and So he took me back to my mother's house. We had a call the day.
他从来没见过我弹钢琴，所以他当时想：这到底是怎么回事？我也不确定是怎么回事。我不想停下来，因为我想：如果我停下来，然后明天早上这情况不发生了怎么办？我的意思是，这挺酷的。我意思是，你不会每天都坐下来开始弹钢琴。所以我觉得这挺不寻常的。让我们，让我们在这儿多待一会儿。当时一定已经是凌晨两点了，我已经筋疲力尽。我的大脑还在飞速运转，依然兴奋不已。所以他把我送回了我母亲家。那天我们通了电话。
I was, you know, beat up and I went to bed and the next morning I woke up and I was paranoid. I was nervous. I was scared. I was like, how am I going to tell my mother? The person that knows me best on this planet. I just hit my head and I'm a little whacked out. How am I going to tell her that I just discovered that I know how to play
我当时，你知道的，浑身酸痛，然后我上床睡觉了。第二天早上醒来时，我感到很偏执。我很紧张。我很害怕。我想：我要怎么告诉我母亲？这个星球上最了解我的人。我刚刚撞了脑袋，现在脑子有点错乱。我要怎么告诉她，我刚刚发现自己会弹钢琴了，
the piano fairly well to a person that's known me my entire life, 40 years. So I said, well, I don't know any other way than to take her to a music store. So I said, we had a cup of coffee and I said, it's front of the music store real quick. And she said, what do you want to buy? And I said, nothing. I said, I just want to show you something real fast. I went teller.
而且弹得相当不错，要对一个认识了我一辈子、整整40年的人说。所以我想，除了带她去乐器行，我别无他法。于是我说，我们喝了杯咖啡，我说，去乐器行前面一趟。她说，你想买什么？我说，什么都不买。我说，我只是想让你快点看个东西。我告诉她。
We get to the music store. We walk in, the salesman says, I don't know, like, you know, he can help you, he wants to sell me something. And I said, if you show me how to get this piano, this digital piano on, that's all I need. And then give me just 10 minutes. So he turns it on, shows me how to turn the darn thing on. I tell my mother to sit down next to me.
我们到了乐器行。走进去，售货员说，我不知道，就像，你知道的，他可以帮忙，他想向我推销东西。我说，如果你教我怎么把这台钢琴——这台数码钢琴打开，这就够了。然后给我10分钟就行。于是他把它打开，教我怎么打开这个该死的东西。我让我母亲坐在我旁边。
What did you play? I don't quite remember what I played that time, but I was doing more of a... I wanted to sing to her for some reason because it was such an emotional thing. And I was going into like... And I just started to kind of chord this and she was looking at me like, whoa, when did this transpire? I mean, she had all kinds of questions right away. And then I just kind of went nuts and started going crazy just to show her, look at this,
你弹了什么？我不太记得当时弹了什么，但我弹得更多的是……不知为什么，我想为她唱歌，因为那是一种非常情绪化的体验。我开始弹奏某种……我开始弹奏和弦，她看着我，眼神仿佛在说：哇，这是什么时候发生的？我的意思是，她马上提出了各种各样的问题。然后我有点情绪失控，开始疯狂地弹奏，只是为了向她展示：看这个，
look at this. And she started crying, she really did say much. It was a very quiet drive home. As you're telling me this, Derek, I almost have the feeling that you are pulling my leg right now because it seems this is not possible. This is just simply not, it could not have happened. You know, well, if I would have had my way, I'm not sure if I would have ended up a piano player.
看这个。她开始哭了，她真的没说太多。回家的车程非常安静。德里克，你跟我说这些的时候，我几乎觉得你现在是在开我的玩笑，因为这似乎是不可能的。这简直不可能，绝不可能发生。你知道的，如果由我做主的话，我不确定自己最终会不会成为一个钢琴家。
I kind of wanted to be a baseball player and I were working the fighting business. So I don't know. And you know what, I invite skepticism because I think when something so beautiful and profound happens, we have to, we have to question. At what stage did you stop questioning that you had a scale? I'm assuming that you were skeptical as well. I mean, you told me that when you went home the first night, you were afraid that it was
我其实想成为一名棒球运动员，而且我一直在做格斗生意。所以我不知道。你知道吗，我欢迎持怀疑态度的人，因为我觉得当如此美丽而深奥的事情发生时，我们必须，我们必须提出质疑。你是在哪个阶段停止怀疑自己拥有这种天赋的？我假设你一开始也是怀疑的。我的意思是，你告诉我第一天回家的时候，你害怕这
going to be a one-day scale and it was going to be gone by the next morning. At what point did you stop questioning it and say, this is actually a new skill that I have? You know, I think you kind of grow into that, getting comfortable with accepting what's transpired in your life. I definitely didn't want it to go away. In the first year or two, it was a little, you know, like, I would wake up thinking, I need to get to a piano. I need to make sure it's still here.
只会维持一天，第二天早上就会消失。你是在哪个时刻停止质疑，并说这实际上是我拥有的新技能的？你知道的，我想你会慢慢适应这种状态，开始接受你生活中发生的事情。我绝对不希望它消失。在第一年或两年里，有点像，你知道的，我醒来时会想：我得去一架钢琴前。我得确保它还在。
And as time went on, I started to understand that, well, the doctors tell me it can go away as fast as it came. And acquired musical savants syndrome. That means you've acquired a gift. And I got to that point where I just accepted the fact that I'm going to enjoy every second of this. Because if I wake up tomorrow and it's gone, I want to be able to say that I did the best I could
随着时间的推移，我开始明白，医生告诉我它可能会像来时一样快地消失。这是获得性音乐学者综合征。这意味着你获得了一种天赋。我到了那个地步，我只是接受了这样一个事实：我要享受这里的每一秒。因为如果我明天醒来它消失了，我想能够说我已经尽力了，
to display it to a society looking in at my life and say, I've been inspired by this, or the human potential is amazing, or the brain is just a magnificent organ that we don't know anything about. And I think it became that comfort knowing that, I'm gonna enjoy it every single second.
把它展现给审视我生活的社会，并说：我受到了启发，或者人类的潜力是惊人的，又或者大脑只是一个我们一无所知的神奇器官。我想这种安慰让我明白，我要享受它的每一分每一秒。
And if it stays beautiful, if it goes away then I guess I'll go get a job. Have you spoken to neurologist who is skeptical about what's happening to you? I think they're all skeptical the moment they walk in the door. I mean, I feel skeptical. I'm sorry, I know that you're a nice guy. You seem like a trustworthy person. Right, right, I expect you to be.
如果它一直这么美妙，如果它消失了，那我想我就会去找份工作。你和对你身上发生的事情持怀疑态度的神经学家谈过吗？我想他们刚进门时都是怀疑的。我的意思是，我自己也觉得很怀疑。对不起，我知道你是个好人。你看上去是个值得信赖的人。对，对，我希望你这么觉得。
But I have the feeling that you're just, this is just one big giant prank. Well, that's because I'm still, I'm articulate and I still have most of my marbles. So I can display the story in a different way than let's say the guy that hit his head and woke up a piano player, but he's not all here. If I asked you to play Twinkle, Twinkleinkle Little Star for me, could you try that?
但我有一种感觉，你只是，这只是一个巨大的恶作剧。那是因我口齿伶俐，而且我的理智基本还在。所以我可以以一种不同的方式来讲述这个故事，比如换作那个撞了脑袋醒来后成了钢琴家、但精神有些不正常的人。如果我请你为我弹奏《小星星》你会试着弹一下吗？
I don't think I can play it. I tried to do happy birthday for a person the other day and I couldn't figure it out. No. Answers no. It's taught with C. Is that this one right here? Oh. Wait. Oh wait Where was that first note then?
我想我弹不了。前几天我尝试为一个人弹《生日快乐》，我都弹不出来。不。答案是没有。它是以C调开始的。是这个吗？哦。等等。哦，等等。那第一个音在哪里？
Wait Where is the... So it's all up and down. Gosh, darn it. I can see it now. I mean, that's kind of there. Thanks for the first note, though. But it's sort of an interesting thing, isn't it?, which is like you don't go up, you don't see someone who says, you know, I can throw a fastball at, I don't know, 140 miles an
等等。在哪里……所以全都是起起伏伏的。天哪，见鬼。我现在能看出来了。我的意思是，大概就是那样。不过还是谢谢你告诉我第一个音。但这是一件挺有趣的事，不是吗？就像你不会看到有人说，你知道的，我可以投出时速140英里的快速球，
hour, but I don't know how to reach out and shake your hand. And to me, your displaying musical ability at one end of the spectrum, whereas playing Twinkle Twinkle Little Star, I can do that. And you find it hard, and I find it just really difficult to understand how you can be so good at the extreme end without knowing the basics.
但我不知道怎么伸手跟你握手。在我看来，你在频谱的一端展现出音乐才能，而弹奏《小星星》对我来说轻而易举，但你却觉得难，而我真的很难理解，一个人怎么能在不了解基础知识的情况下，就在极端的一端表现得如此出色。我和你一样。我站在你这边。我也对此着迷。这会打扰到你吗？你拥有这种能力会让你感到担心吗？
I'm right there with you. I'm on your side. I'm fascinated with that too. Does it disturb you? Does it worry you that you have this ability? No, I mean I'm a Christian kid, so I think I think this is what God wants me. I think this has already been penned out my story. I How else I mean I have to live with this every day, so if I sit and beat my own mind up about,
不，我的意思是，我是个基督徒，所以我认为这是上帝想让我做的事。我认为我的故事早就写好了。不然还能怎样——我的意思是，我每天都得带着这个生活，所以如果我坐在这里折磨自己的大脑，
is this nature versus nurture and nature and all this nonsense? But I mean, I've talked to the best doctors, the smart doctors, and the planet. And they all got a different little input. Now, I've got something different to say about it. Most all of them are skeptic when I walk in and most all of them when I walk out are right here with me. Have any of them suggested treatments? Yes, yes.
这是先天还是后天，以及所有这些无聊的废话？但我的意思是，我和最好的医生、这个星球上最聪明的医生谈过。他们每个人都有不同的见解。现在，我对它有不同的看法。当我走进去时，几乎所有人都是怀疑论者；而当我走出来时，几乎所有人都站在我这边。他们有人建议过治疗吗？有的，有的。
The Dr. Reeves at the Mayo Clinic when I was filming with the Discovery Channel, he was fascinated with this as well. And he said, the best way to fair him to explain is like a roller coaster. If you get on a roller coaster that doesn't stop, sooner or later it's going to get tiring. So maybe we suggest slowing down the stimulant,
我在和探索频道拍摄时，梅奥诊所的里夫斯医生也对这一点着迷。他说，用最好的方式来向你解释，就像过山车一样。如果你坐上一辆不停下来的过山车，迟早你会感到疲惫。所以也许我们建议放慢刺激，
the overstimulated brain, you're firing these neurons at a pace that's unheard of. So let's try some. Seize your medication to shut those down, right? I don't know understand how it works, but I do know it slows down the firing of the neurons. Why would I want to take synthetic drugs and mask something possibly that I'm enjoying to the point where I don't want it to slow down and go away.
过度刺激的大脑，你以一种前所未有的速度激发这些神经元。所以让我们试试。服用药物来关闭这些神经元，对吧？我不知道它是怎么运作的，但我确实知道它会减慢神经元的放电速度。我为什么要服用合成药物来掩盖某些我正在享受的事情，直到我不希望它减慢并消失的程度呢？
I'll take the hyperness and the ADHD and OCD and all that garbage that comes with this maybe. What if it has a consequence where you are burning your brain at a level that is not healthy for you? I mean, so for example, let's say... you are burning your brain at a level that is not healthy for you. I mean, so for example, let's... Then I guess I go down on fire, baby. And that's how the story ends, and I'm good with that.
也许我会接受随之而来的高度兴奋、多动症、强迫症和所有这些垃圾。如果它会产生一种以不健康程度燃烧大脑的后果呢？我的意思是，举个例子……以不健康程度燃烧大脑的后果呢？我的意思是，举个例子……那么我想我就会在烈火中燃烧吧，宝贝。这就是故事的结局，我能接受。
You're still the guy who would die for the swoop football of the swimming pool. Yeah. Of course, Derek Amato isn't the only person with a quads of Ancindro. Others have experienced the profound changes that come with this condition. They are so motivated, they are in love with what they're doing. It's almost like an extension of who they are. Also, I'm going to challenge Derek to play the studio wall. I see on this wall, I see these squares. Some of them have different depths, so the full squares almost feel like a whole note to me. Keep listening, it'll make more sense soon.
你仍然是那个会为泳池里的橄榄球而拼命的人。是的。当然，德里克·阿马托并不是唯一一个患有获得性学者综合征的人。其他人也经历过这种病情带来的深刻变化。他们非常有动力，他们热爱自己所做的事。这几乎就像是他们自我的延伸。另外，我要挑战德里克去弹奏演播室的墙壁。我看到这面墙上，我看到了这些方块。其中一些有不同的深度，所以满格的方块对我来说几乎就像一个全音符。继续听下去，很快就会更有意义了。
I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain from NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This week on the show, we're looking at the specific moments people lose something big and how that change can point them in new directions. Before the break, Derrick Amato told us a story of how he became a musician after a head injury. Before the accident, he couldn't play the piano, but after, his musical talent was just undeniable. If this is the first time you're hearing our show, I have a confession to make. I'm a card-carrying rationalist. When surprising things happen, I don't call them miracles. I look for explanations.
我是香卡·维丹塔姆，您正在收听的是NPR的《隐藏的大脑》。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。本周节目中，我们将探讨人们失去重要事物的特定时刻，以及这种改变如何为他们指明新的方向。在休息之前，德里克·阿马托向我们讲述了他如何在头部受伤后成为一名音乐家的故事。事故发生前，他不会弹钢琴，但事故发生后，他的音乐才华不容置疑。如果这是你第一次收听我们的节目，我得坦白一件事。我是个根正苗红的理性主义者。当令人惊奇的事情发生时，我不会称之为奇迹。我寻找解释。
Derrick's very charming, his story's amazing, but I found myself asking over and over how something like this could happen. That's when I came by a couple of researchers who've spent years studying people who've suddenly acquired savant-like gifts. Darrell Treffert is a psychiatrist in Wisconsin. He studied Derek. And I must say that in his case, I'm, you know, was a sturdle as you about the fact that he went to the piano and knew where to place his fingers and so forth.
德里克的魅力十足，他的故事非常惊人，但我发现自己不断地在问，这种事怎么可能会发生呢。就在那时，我遇到了一对研究人员，他们花了多年时间研究那些突然获得类似学者天赋的人。达勒姆·特雷弗特是威斯康星州的一位精神病学家。他研究过德里克。我必须说，在他的病例中，我和你一样，对于他走到钢琴前却知道把手指放在哪里等等感到十分惊讶。
The reason that I'm inclined to accept that is because I've seen that in some of these other cases, although probably not quite as abrupt as he, but, and to me at least, that having seen a lot of sub-hands when I see some of these acquired sub-hand cases, it is really quite jarring. I don't know if you remember what Derek said about his injury. He leaped across the swimming pool for the football, and when he came down hard, he heard what sounded like an explosion. And I miscalculated the depth, obviously, and I hit the upper left side of my face. The left side of his face.
我倾向于接受这一点的原因是因为我在其他一些病例中也看到过这种情况，尽管可能没有他那么突然，但对我来说，至少在见过很多学者之后，当我看到其中一些获得性学者的病例时，确实感到相当震惊。我不知道你是否还记得德里克关于他受伤的描述。他为了接橄榄球跃过泳池，当他重重落下时，他听到了类似爆炸的声音。显然我错判了深度，我的脸部左上方撞上了。他脸部的左侧。
That's an important clue. In general, in Savon Syndrome itself, whether congenital or acquired, there tends to be a more left brain injury with right brain compensation and the right brain areas or ability that seem to emerge have to do with art music and mathematics, actually. Art, music, and math, all skills that involve pattern recognition. At the University of Pennsylvania, cognitive psychologist Scott Barry Kaufman said, think about it. These are the skills you might imagine are built into the architecture of the brain. In other words, we might come hardwired for certain kinds of activities.
这是一个重要的线索。总的来说，在学者综合征本身中，无论是先天性的还是获得性的，往往都伴随着更多的左脑损伤和右脑代偿，而显得浮现出来的右脑区域或能力，实际上与艺术、音乐和数学有关。艺术、音乐和数学，所有这些技能都涉及模式识别。宾夕法尼亚大学的认知心理学家斯科特·巴里·考夫曼说，想想看。这些技能你可以想象是内置在大脑结构中的。换句话说，我们可能对某些类型的活动天生就带有硬编码。
This is the insight that helped me see that Derek might not be pulling a prank. Most of us, in fact, effortlessly learn things. Just like Derek says, he never took classes to learn piano, you probably didn't take formal lessons to learn your first language. The truth is that a lot of things we learn in life were not done deliberately. When we were very young and the teachers of 2 and 4 we learned a huge amount of new words and learned the grammatical structure of our language automatically without we didn't like sit down when we were two years old and say, right, I'm going to learn all the
正是这种洞察力帮助我认识到德里克可能不是在开玩笑。事实上，我们大多数人都在毫不费力地学习东西。正如德里克所说，他从未上过学习钢琴的课，你大概也没有上过正式课程来学习你的第一门语言。事实是，我们在生活中学到的很多东西都不是刻意去做的。在我们很小的时候，比如两岁和四岁时，我们自动学了大量的生词和语言的语法结构，我们并没有在两岁时坐下来，说：“好啦，我要学习所有的
grammatical syntax and what it all means and so we have these structures that help us learn. If you look at it this way most people have skills that might seem so not like to a visitor from another planet we learn these skills effortlessly in fact it doesn't even feel like learning it feels like fun. What makes savants unique in other words is not that their brains do amazing things. All brains do amazing things. What's different is that they're demonstrating effortless learning in domains that usually call for sustained effort. Now, I'm not going to tell you you should go out and bang your head against the floor of a swimming pool to learn to play the
语法句法及其全部含义”，所以我们拥有这些帮助我们学习的结构。如果从这个角度来看，大多数人的技能可能对来自另一个星球的访客来说不像是在学习，我们毫不费力地学习这些技能，事实上，它甚至不感觉像学习，它感觉像是玩耍。换句话说，学者的独特之处不在于他们的大脑能做惊人的事情。所有的大脑都能做惊人的事情。不同之处在于，他们在通常需要持续努力的领域展示了不费力的学习。现在，我不是在告诉你，你应该去撞击游泳池底来学习弹
piano. The vast majority of concussions don't produce an ingenious, they have terrible outcomes. But Derek's story does suggest, even to this card-carrying rationalist, that we have worlds within us, gifts, that we do not realize that we possess. When I look at these savants, what I see at the core that I think is, offers a lot of inspiration to humanity, is that they are so motivated. They are in love with what they're doing.
钢琴。绝大多数脑震荡不会造就天才，它们会带来可怕的结局。但德里克的故事确实表明，即使对于我这个根正苗红的理性主义者来说，我们的内心也拥有我们未曾意识到自己拥有的世界和天赋。当我看着这些学者时，我看到的核心——我认为这为人类提供了很多启发——是他们动力十足。他们热爱自己所做的事。
It's almost like an extension of who they are. To me, that offers a lot of hope or inspires me that perhaps all of us can find that vehicle that really allows us to sing. As Derek was playing the piano in NPR studio one, I noticed there was a wall behind him. It had soundproofing, hollow wooden cubes, each of a different depth. Derek had told me that when he plays,
这几乎就像是他们自我的延伸。对我来说，这提供了许多希望，或者启发了我：也许我们所有人都能找到那个真正让我们放声歌唱的载体。当德里克在NPR第一演播室弹奏钢琴时，我注意到他身后有一面墙。它有隔音效果，是中空的木质方块，每个方块的深度都不同。德里克曾告诉我，当他弹奏时，
he sees squares floating by him. So I asked him to turn around, look at the wall, and tell me what he saw. I see on this wall, I see these squares. Some of them have different depths. So the full squares almost feel like a whole note to me. I ask Derek to play the wall for me.
他看到方块在他身边漂浮。所以我请他转过身，看着墙壁，告诉我他看到了什么。我看到这面墙上，我看到了这些方块。其中一些有不同的深度。所以满格的方块对我来说几乎就像一个全音符。我请德里克为我弹奏这面墙。
I see low notes because all the depth. You see the dark ones that are filled in all the way? They stand out, so I see low notes like... Now I'm in the middle boxes. See where I'm at now in those middle boxes, so those are... And that's a whole different... Now we're getting into a whole different thing. Now I'm getting excited. You got any more walls with the look at me.
我看到了低音，因为所有的深度。你看到那些完全填满的暗色方块了吗？它们很显眼，所以我看到了低音，比如……现在我到了中间的方块。看我现在所在的中间方块，所以那些是……那是一个完全不同的……现在我们进入了一个完全不同的东西。现在我开始兴奋了。你还有没有别的墙让我看看。
So you were just playing the wall? That's what you were playing with. I was playing what I wanted. I was playing what I wanted. So I started here. Okay, so imagine that's the music bar. So I played the top one. I'll do it again. I'll do it precisely exactly like I started here. Okay, so imagine that's the music bar. Yeah. So I played the top one. I'll do it again.
所以你刚才是在弹墙壁？这就是你弹奏的对象。我弹奏的是我想弹的。我弹奏的是我想弹的。所以我从这里开始。好吧，所以想象那是乐谱小节。所以我弹了上面的那个。我再做一次。我会精确地、一模一样地按照我从这里开始的方式来弹。好吧，所以想象那是乐谱小节。是的。所以我弹了上面的那个。我再做一次。
I'll do it precisely exactly like I saw it. Music And then it changes to this bar. We've moved down down now and now we're going to move down to the next bar of music and I see. And we'll go back up to the top. And then we can make it jazz. And that's, and I mean, it just goes on and on and on and on. And these walls could be dangerous because I wouldn't want to sleep at all.
我会精确地、一模一样地按照我看到的方式来弹。音乐然后它变成了这个小节。我们现在向下移动了，现在我们要移动到下一个乐谱小节，我看到了。然后我们回到顶部。然后我们可以把它变成爵士乐。而且，我的意思是，它就这样没完没了地继续下去。这些墙可能会很危险，因为我可能会完全不想睡觉。
If I had walls like this in my house. Are you telling me that you have never played the piece of music you just played for me in your life before? No. And this third row might even be a whole different composition. That's what I'm saying. The depths of those blocks, those middle rows and those circles in the middle, that's what these are to me. That's what...
如果我家里有这样的墙。你是说你这辈子从来没有为我弹过你刚才弹的那段音乐吗？没有。第三排甚至可能是完全不同的作品。这就是我要说的。那些方块的深度，中间的那些行和中间的那些圆圈，对我来说就是这些。那就是……
Those are rolling are to me. That's what... Those are rolling patterns to me. And then those chunky ones on the top, that's where I see that... And it just changes like that, suddenly. And then I moved out of the next one, and it's a whole different flow. That's Derek Amato, playing the wall in NPR Studio One. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Cara McGurk-Allison with help from NILT VULT.
那些对我来说是滚动的图案。然后上面那些厚实的块，那就是我看到……然后它就这样变了，突然之间。然后我移到了下一个，那是完全不同的流动。那是德里克·阿马托，在NPR第一演播室弹奏墙壁。本期《隐藏的大脑》由卡拉·麦克古克-埃里森制作，尼尔特·伏尔特提供了帮助。
Our staff includes Maggie Penman, Jenny Schmitt, Chris Bander-Ev and Renee Clar. Our new supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Find more hidden brain on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, give us a review. It helps. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的员工包括玛吉·佩恩曼、珍妮·施密特、克里斯·班德-埃夫和蕾妮·克拉尔。我们的新主管制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上查找更多《隐藏的大脑》，并在您当地的公共广播电台上收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，请给我们写个评价。这很有帮助。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。你本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。